hey what is up guys I'm kph D here 300
hours of video are uploaded to YouTube
every minute that's a lot in fact the
time it took you to get to this point in
the video about a fresh hour of video
was uploaded somewhere on YouTube so
there's plenty of content that's been
watched
no times and plenty of content that's
been watched millions of times but
here's the thing all this has to go
somewhere and it's not just spit
directly back to you you're not watching
the originally uploaded file that's
where YouTube's processing comes in so
this is YouTube's processing explained
so if you follow me on Twitter you
already know that every time I upload a
new video I tweet uploading that's just
when I'm seeing this I'm uploading the
file from my computer to YouTube's
servers and then when the upload is done
I tweet processing processing is a
necessary process and for videos like
this the final file size can be a couple
of gigabytes and if YouTube tried to
play back that original uncompressed
video file for everyone that tried to
watch it unless you have Google Fiber or
some crazy fast internet connection it
would look a lot like this
a smartphone it would likely either
overheat or destroy your data cap
whichever came first you just can't
handle that much data so YouTube has to
compress the original upload into a
bunch of different file formats and
resolutions that anyone can watch so
every single video that gets uploaded to
YouTube gets processed and that
processing spits out multiple versions
of each video so this video for example
has a 240p version a 360p version a 480p
version a 720p version a 1080p version a
1440p version and a 2160p version
youtube does this so it can dynamically
switch you in between which version of
the video you're watching so it might
start you off at the 720p version and if
your internet connection is really good
and things seem to be moving pretty
smoothly it might bump you up to the
1080p version so if you might notice a
couple seconds in the video it gets a
little bit clearer that's what's
happening sometimes the opposite happens
sometimes you move to a poorer
connection strength and you might switch
from 720p on your phone down to 360p
basically YouTube is constantly
determining every few seconds which
processed version of the video to show
you based on your connection strength
and your playback status and all this is
to avoid ever showing you that Spinney
buffering bar now if you're feeling
daring and your computer and your
connection strength are up to it you can
click to watch this video in full 2160p
or full 4k if your device supports it
and that's pretty high quality but even
that full 4k video here on YouTube is
not the same as the original file that
was uploaded this process version is
compressed to about a tenth of the
original file size of course it hasn't
always been this way you know up until
March 2008 the highest quality video you
could watch on YouTube was 240 P and
then a couple months later we got an HQ
button to move you to bump up to 360 P
so it's not always been super high
quality when I first started uploading
YouTube the highest quality it's
supported with 720p so every mkbhd video
was 720p HD back in the day but of
course now we have all sorts of not only
resolutions but codecs to help compress
video and help be able to watch super
high quality video smoothly all over
YouTube also just to throw out my
personal theory this adaptive bitrate
streaming is why youtubers can't see the
analytics on who is watching the video
and what resently
who watches in 4k I mean we might be
able to get analytics on who clicks to
watch in certain resolutions but even
that doesn't guarantee you stay at 4k
for the entire video either way YouTube
processing is very complex but also very
important and constantly happening yes
it does break sometimes but it's also
updated sometimes with newer codecs and
newer methods but bottom line next time
you see your favorite youtuber tweet
that their new video is processing you
know exactly what that means thanks for
watching
base